clearly my Italian could use some work
luciano pavarotti so I asked Jordan to
sign me up for a beginner lesson in
Italian but we wound up in an advanced
immersion class instead long story short
he hello
ciao ciao where's everyone from in the
class me ray he does not have the
vocabulary of the Italian language but
he has the drama hands she has the
authority in this room she is the
teacher she is in control they are well
behaved they listen and look at you I am
paraphrasing America you see we're
representing our country you speak
Italian the Mandarin Cantonese Mandarin
neoman here you've eaten a brochure
state it again twice even a brochure
twice
Jotham to say so I sustained she's
asking if I'm your assistant
no he does not do your body cause I
cannot speak your time no I tell ya no
but I can pretend you you I have not
felt this hated at a table since
Thanksgiving in Boston two years ago
okay I should probably explain to
students left ray can you say why you
think those two left okay
you